in the long history of tension between
police and the black community the
neighborhood of watts holds a
significant place the riots of 1965 were
born out of a confrontation between a
white police officer and a black
motorist the racial tensions of Los
Angeles would boil over again 27 years
later they remain historical markers of
inequality and injustice what's today is
gang territory this is Jordan downs
this is territory claimed by the grape
Street Crips but an LAPD team here is
trying to lower the tension build trust
what's called a Community Safety
Partnership is breaking down some
age-old barriers we are making massive
improvements I think the narrative right
now is that we're only looking at a very
negative side of police work we're all
in this together and it only gets better
if we all work together I think would
happen in Minneapolis everybody knows
was beyond evil that's not a reflection
of law enforcement for many in the
community it's working the police come
through you know they do their job they
see somebody doing something right of
course they don't stop Jesse's less
hopeful about policing nationwide I
don't think it's gonna be no better not
no time soon you know unless some
drastic was to happen with it they
change their whole policy you know I'm
hard dealing with people you know but I
know I'll see you happy
because always some bad apples in the
bunch you know like every police
department the LAPD's been changed by
the killing of George Floyd chokeholds
are temporarily banned pending a review
and de-escalation tactics they've used
here for years and now the talk of the
country do you think change has to come
as a result of what we've seen clearly
as it relates to said officers be
involved in situations where they're
abusing their power or things of that
nature absolutely good officers but
cannot stand officers that are not doing
their job the right way the unit's
success stories in watts of those like
Marilyn Gonzales police have helped get
her a college scholarship to pursue her
boxing career this is a long road though
in my own relations have been with the
officers who mentor here like we've been
working together for the last two years
and it's a great relationship when I'm
outside on my own that relationship
doesn't carry over an officer who pulls
me over or engages me you know outside
of this community doesn't know me and so
the relation it's it's a dual existence
and balancing that is is I think the
black tax like that's what we've had to
do for quite a long time when it would
occur dover minneapolis it you're
talking eight minutes and 46 seconds I
have to explain that to my kids and it
impacted me deeply and now I got to come
on come to work but the same uniform on
and be professional and so that's the
hard part about being a person of color
and when you take the uniform off still
an african-american but in all reality
we need more people that reflect the
community that we're serving here that
starts with building relationships
America is searching for answers this
they say can be a step in the right
direction
like Milam Sky News Los Angeles